tu as plusieurs territoires merci la
parole est à monsieur guillaume
chevrollier merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre le
remaniement ministériel a des
conséquences inattendues
la tentative de refonte de votre
majorité se paie au prix cher pour
l'ouest de la france alors que cette
grande région agricole souffre déjà la
voile a impacté par la capacité du
président de la république à prendre une
décision je veux parler bien sûr de
l'annnonce du référendum sur notre dame
des landes
comment concilier un ex premier ministre
devenu ministre des affaires étrangères
grand défenseur de ce projet avec des
écologistes divisés sur quantité de
sujets sauf celui de notre dame des
landes
la défausse trouvé par le président de
la république pose plus de problèmes
qu'elle n'en résout
c'est un déni de démocratie ce
référendum est malvenue alors que les
urnes bien à plusieurs reprises et
encore dernièrement aux élections
régionales de portée des équipes
favorable à ce projet quelle est sa base
juridique qui peut l'organiser
qui peut voter le seul département de la
loire atlantique
sûrement pas alors que plusieurs
départements sont concernés et financent
cet aéroport son résultat est d'ailleurs
déjà contesté par les organisations
écologistes et les analystes qui annonce
d'ores et déjà qu'il ne le reconnaîtrons
pas ce référendum montre une nouvelle
fois l'incapacité de ce gouvernement à
prendre des mesures courageuses
n'aurait-il qu'un objectif retarder la
décision jouer la durée avant une année
électorale
après la libye des décisions de justice
voilà qu'on se retranche derrière un
référendum
l'autorité de l'état est à nouveau
bafoué
monsieur le premier ministre je vais
donc vous demander de faire cesser cette
mascarade de faire appliquer la loi de
respecter la justice qui par 155
décision autorise la lancée des travaux
de cet aéroport du grand ouest
merci monsieur chevalier la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls sur le député j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion vous le savez de m'exprimer
devant la représentation nationale à
propos du dossier et du projet notre
dame des landes et je vous le confirme
je ne change pas et nous ne changeons
pas de position oui je le répète ici
le projet de transfert de l'art port de
nantes sur le site de notre dame des
landes est un projet important pour le
développement économique et romain de ce
territoire et aussi pour la réduction
des nuisances subies par les habitants
de la métropole de nantes et pour la
préservation de l'environnement
et je rappelle que le projet a été
déclaré d'utilité publique en 2008
en juillet dernier le tribunal
administratif de nantes a rejeté
l'ensemble des recours déposés contre
les arrêtés préfectoraux qui autorisait
le lancement des travaux
ce projet vous l'avez rappelé est
soutenu par l'ensemble des collectivités
locales concernées et nous savons vous
et moi comme les élus de territoire que
il faudra procéder au début des travaux
au moins d'octobre prochain et aux
évacuations qui s'impose parce que sinon
il n'y aura pas de projet c'est ça la
réalité et donc personne ne veut ou ne
peut perdre de temps sur ce dossier
cependant et je crois il vous plaît en
nouveauté d'hostilité pons et en toute
responsabilité parce que je sais parce
que le ministre de l'intérieur le sait
aussi bien que moi que l'évacuation de
la zad l'évacuation de ce territoire qui
est occupé
pas un certain nombre de personnes qui
de toute façon précise paul à toute
initiative du gouvernement ou des élus
et à tout acte démocratique
nous savons que cette évacuation et
laisser la responsabilité du
gouvernement de l'intégrer se passera
dans des conditions difficiles et c'est
pour cela qu'avec le président de la
république nous avons considéré qu'il
fallait donner une légitimité
supplémentaire à ce dossier et chacun
sera placé devant ses responsabilités
c'est pour cela qu'en effet en nous
donnant encore quelques semaines un mois
au plus avec la ministre de l'écologie
les consultations nécessaires auront
lieu à la fois sur la question qui sera
posée sur le périmètre de la
consultation et sur les modalités parce
que personne qui s'ignore ça a été
rappelé depuis jeudi de gagner toute une
série de problématiques juridiques
mais cette consultation aura lieu elle
leur a force de loi d'une certaine
manière au delà de la loi est de l'avis
des élus
mesdames messieurs les députés et c'est
un commentaire plus personnel que
j'apporte dans la situation que le gros
nez creux qui n'ont plus la bassure se
tait les potins et j'irai jusqu'au bout
babin par giuly rhin ces interruptions
ses appels à la démission
ce comportement vont à l'encontre
exactement de ce que les français
attendent de la représentation nationale
et de responsables politiques
consulter les citoyens sur ce sujet là
avant l'été s'impose et donnera de la
force nécessaire au projet
merci monsieur